to top off the day really because this
is sort of a year in review here it is
list of things I Hate Everything
irritates me I hate watching sports I
hate all this I hate shout outs I hate
when I see people in a hot tub IMAX I
[__] hate IMAX I hate balloons I hate
that they go into the ocean I hate that
they hurt the sea life I hate being on a
boat I hate being in hotels I hate
leaving the house I hate parades I hate
being pranked I hate being around other
famous people I hate orchestr fun I hate
candles I hate candles I hate candles
fire belongs outside now I'm so angry at
that OIC I hate OIC I hate people who
wear one necklace I hate reading I hate
the drawing of the co virus I hate
taking breaks I hate that word Grace I
hate to cook I hate the radio hall of
fame I hate when people go oh he's woke
I hate when people worship anybody I
hate thetick I hate to burst everyone's
bubble I just hate the whole thing I
hate bursting bubbles I do and now to
cap off our Monumental show I play you
things I love for the first time in 2023
what yes here is the list I love arguing
with people I love Batman I Love College
I love secrets and I love [__] I love
having sex with my wife I just love my
breakfast I love gay rights I love
having a disease no one's ever heard of
I love a sheer shirt where you see the
nips I love hey now I love my pets I
love peanut butter I love real estate
porn I love rural places I love
scientists I love interviewing men who
have a big penis I love nudity I love
the conspiracy theories I love the FBI I
love going on a walk I love metam musal
I love when news people are comedians oh
I love my bed so much I love radio I
love movies with zombies and titties and
ass love all our fans I love it wow what
a what a what a show I had no idea you
express so much love in this show I was
uncomfortable hearing how much love I
gave out this year